[Musique]
je ne suis pas du tout hostile à ces
processus où on may be nice et mes
citoyens pour éclairer en complément de
la démocratie représentative aussi pour
sensibiliser
j'avais été un des deux experts
nationaux lorna comme 21 on suive un
protocole mondial d'une consultation
planétaire sur la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique mais selon moi
ça doit être en parallèle des processus
démocratiques alors ce que tu
indispensable c'est qu' un débat
démocratique sur la façon de gérer la
pandémie en général et sur la campagne
de vaccination de l'autre et de ce point
de vue là la france qui est extrêmement
retard la constitution d'un panel de
citoyens de prendre 20 personnes qui va
pouvoir délibérer dans des conditions
théoriquement presque idéale pour est en
soi être une bonne initiative elle
permettrait de faire valoir des points
de vue venons de zone diversifier notre
société mais des points de vue qui sont
pas comme ça brut mais qui sont frottés
les uns avec les autres qui sont
enrichis par un matériel important par
des auditions bref il s'agit d'un
exercice démocratique potentiellement
très intéressant il n'y a pas qu'une
forme de représentation politique
on a aujourd'hui une forme de
représentation politique qui
essentiellement élective est là sa
validité et en même temps on voit bien
qu'elle est largement à bout de souffle
si on pense que c'est sûr elle est
simplement sur elle que doit reposer
tout de mécanismes de représentation les
citoyen et ce n'est pas seulement vrai
en france c'est tendance généralisée
dans les pays occidentaux on la défiance
par rapport à leurs représentants
politiques élus et ils ont à juste titre
l'impression que certains l'entente élus
défendent
bien souvent voir la plupart du temps
des intérêts de boutique des intérêts
personnels plutôt que de se tourner vers
l'intérêt général comme leur mission
devrait être sensé désorienté et du coup
il ya d'autres formes de représentation
politique qui peut se développer
notons que l'initiative sur la
vaccination se tient dans les locaux
étaient organisées ou organisée par le
conseil économique social économique à
société civile organisée c'est une forme
de représentation
et puis leur présentation que l'on
pourrait dire appuyé fort le tirage au
sort désigne un nouveau type de
représentants je pense qu'on démocratie
représentative le premier garant de la
démocratie c'est les chante le dialogue
entre le pouvoir exécutif et le pouvoir
législatif c'est-à-dire les
représentants élus par des citoyens
voire se hisser au niveau de l'intérêt
général la difficulté on a là c'est que
au fond depuis la crise inter on a le
sentiment on peut comprendre les
éléments d'urgence de rapidité de
décision mais qu'au fond le parlement a
été assez peu mobilisés sur les grandes
questions ou en tout cas même informé le
risque et ses bars ont convergé avec
yves sintomer c'est que la façon dont
les choses se font apparaissent puisse
apparaître comme il fut une façon de
gadgets pour se défausser
[Musique]
je vois ce type de processus ne peut
faire appel à des citoyens que ma seule
éléments d'éclairage
si on devait leur accorder plus
d'importance on s'inscrirait dans une
conception néolibérale de la politique
qui est la cause de la très nice
démocratique qui entraîne en retour les
passions tristes les populismes et le
nationalisme donc la discussion avec ils
sentent au maire est une discussion très
profonde sur l'analyse des raisons de la
prise démocratique car évidemment selon
que l'on fait est des l'analyse on n'a
pas les mêmes types de réponses à cette
même crise enfin quand je fais pas
effectivement il ne faut pas avoir peur
des terres une généralisation ce type de
dispositif les thèmes sur lesquels il
est important de pouvoir déployer ce
genre de dispositifs sont des thèmes qui
soit relève des questions du futur soit
relève de question de règles du jeu les
règles électorales par exemple il ya
aucune raison raisonnable pour que ce
soit le parti au pouvoir qui détermine
les règles électorales souvent en sa
faveur
bien sûr et on a eu x changement depuis
quelques décennies france le ce point de
vue là c'est délétère troisièmement des
questions sur lesquelles il ya des
controverses extrêmement fort
extrêmement profond et donc il faut
essayer de sortir par le haut et puis
peut être aussi des questions plus
ponctuelles lorsque l'on juge un
responsable politique qui a des
fonctions ministérielles ont peut être
que des jury citoyen pourrait un peu
comme dans les jurys d'assises avoir
cette fonction de juger les responsables
politiques en fonction y compris le
présent de la république qui aujourd'hui
est comme on le sait est irresponsable